cómo
por favor
hola gracias pues voy a platicar un
poquito de mi historia que aunque
ahorita no parece porque siempre fui muy
flaquita soy futbolista pero mis
músculos nunca se desarrollaron pero
bueno si juego bien yo juego fútbol
práctico fútbol desde que tengo 3 años
de edad mi familia es árabe y mexicana
entonces se puede dar un poco de idea
cómo viene el tema del machismo de las
dos culturas que están bastante
enfocadas al hombre y yo soy hija mayor
y soy nieta mayor entonces él ya que me
parece con un balón de fútbol pues
digamos que no fue la mejor noticia para
nadie por un lado tenía una abuelita de
un lado como de oye mira el ballet norte
el tutú rosa tan bonito tan estético o
mira la gimnasia puede ser una mejor
opción y yo no soltaba mi balón de
fútbol era lo máximo que me ha pasado
pero desde entonces crecí siempre con
toda la gente alrededor diciéndome que
el fútbol no era para mí porque yo era
niña sus imagínense lo que es sembrar
una semilla en un niño o una niña de esa
edad y decirle que algo no es para él o
para ella porque eres niño o eres niña
no puedes cambiar tu género tampoco es
como que lo quieres cambiar y no
entiendes por qué algo que te hace tan
feliz te dicen que no es para ti
género pero bueno pues yo soy un poco
mes ya cuando me gustan las cosas y
seguí jugando a fútbol crecí jugando
fútbol con puros niños que he hecho es
la historia que tenemos normalmente las
futbolistas siempre era yo y por los
niños en la escuela de hecho me conocían
como la niña que juega fútbol sabe para
qué neta me crean como yo era la única
que juega planea fútbol y era yo
en algún momento me atreví a pedir la
santa que me trajera un balón unos tacos
y unos guantes de portero porque quería
jugar en la privada con mis amigos pero
no me había atrevido a pedírselo porque
toda la gente me decía que jugar fútbol
estaba mal porque era para niños sucio
me moría de ganas físico como le voy a
pedir a santa se lo pido si no me lo
trae ni como la reclamó como luego echar
la culpa si realmente yo estoy haciendo
algo que no debería de hacer pero tenía
tantas ganas que dije puso a escribir mi
cartita la hice la manera en la carta se
fue y llegó el día de navidad baje a
sumarme a largo marco que está muy
nerviosa no dormí nada desde que lo pedí
estaba muy nervioso porque de verdad no
es broma yo sentí que estaba haciendo
algo ilegal fatal lo que estoy haciendo
estoy metiendo bastante en un problemón
y neta ni como reclamarle así no me lo
traje
no gracias o sea fue mi culpa tus bajé y
me asomé hablar con 3 123 y me asomé
a ver quién dice que no había regalos
quien dice que había regalos todos somos
creyentes de santo en este foro muy bien
veo que la mayoría perfecto y están en
lo correcto pueden seguir creyendo ahí
estaba mi balón mis tacos y mis guantes
pero qué creen
eran todos rosas si todos balón rosa
tacos rosas o antes rosas y por la
manera muy linda es antes y me como está
padrísimo que juegas fútbol pero hoy el
gobierno se te olvide que eres niña
gracias ok vale
pues bueno llegó el día también de las
famosas rectas del parque de villaverde
es así como bajo las rectas no champions
league así de cuando era chiquito este y
era igual puros niños y me invitaron a
mí mis amigos dije bueno ya la hizo yo
les dije no conoce a cristiano ronaldo
pero yo ya me veía ahí no llegué a
larreta al parque de llegar y ver
como a 50 chavitos jugando fútbol ya
sabes gritando desastre y yo me queda
sumada atrás de un árbol así viendo hoy
diciendo gusta pues va nada no había
niños sus agarre en uniforme remangue
así como me ven ahorita lleva una
gorrita y me la puse para atrás
y entré a la cancha con mis amigos así
la niña tiene crisis de identidad pero
todo bien y me borra igual era rosa así
que tú digas que así todos me veía pues
no conmigo rita para atrás pero rosa
pero era una manera en la que yo quería
llegar a identificarme justamente con el
público al que estaba llegando porque
cada vez que llegaba a un lugar a jugar
fut y había siempre niños pues obvio me
veían raro no me pasaban el balón no me
escogían en los equipos y yo ya sabía a
new del trío era tener que llegar a
demostrar todo el primero justo llegaba
a balón balón no ya me la pasaba escoger
en el equipo no me escogían el momento
en el que me cogían y yo lograba agarrar
la pelota y empezaba a jugar como la
gorra para atrás está dando frutos
resulta que no sólo juega sino que juega
muy bien empieza a meter goles y
terminaba siendo la sensación ya al
final así de que me ventana el balón
dale beso y me lo regresa hasta que nos
casamos y te pongo un balón en vez de un
anillo perfecto pero el tema es que
siempre yo tenía que llegar a demostrar
jamás me tocó llegar a un foro en el que
dijeran ahora les escogemos era como
hasta el último siempre y yo tenía que
buscar el balón porque no me lo pasaba
y así crecí toda mi vida teniendo que
hacer un lugar y siempre con toda la
gente que me rodeaba diciéndome que el
fútbol no era para mí por ser mujer hace
unos años me invitan a participar en un
blog en el que éramos empresarias y
aparte deportistas y líder a platicar
cómo es que el deporte te aptitudes para
el liderazgo el emprendimiento el
trabajo en equipo que es bastante
poderoso y yo escribí acerca la igualdad
de género en el fútbol y en este
artículo yo promoví a la creación de una
liga femenil por resulta que articuló se
viraliza en redes sociales y me empiezan
a llegar miles de mensajes mamás tías
papas o llevar a mi hija juega pero no
lo aceptan en la escuela porque la
escuela solo hay equipo de niños hoy
llegó era mi niña quiere jugar en el
parque en la tarde pero pues no les
cogen en los equipos porque nada más hay
retos para chavos y aunque eso alertó es
trigo va a veintitantos años después de
que yo empecé a jugar está todo igual no
ha cambiado nada todas las niñas que hoy
quieren jugar les pasa exactamente lo
mismo que pasó en todo ese tiempo pues
me marcan para hacerme una llamada usted
es un periódico recordó este deporte
súper heavy fuera te queremos
entrevistar de tu campaña de fútbol esta
poderosísima
ay mi campaña que era un artículo de
opinión sí claro si yo les voy y les
hable mi campaña no se preocupen yo dije
campaña a campaña pues va a campaña ley
y tanto todo lo que estaba pasando dije
alguien tiene que ir a hacer las cosas
alguien tiene que echarse la capa al
hombro y salir a hablar en pro de la
mujer y el fútbol pues fui a hablar de
mi campaña de fútbol y ahí me marcan
para tele y de me marcan para radio y de
ahí me empiezan a marcar las revistas y
de repente resulta que mi artículo
opinión ya era una campaña y yo traía un
desastre ya a favor de la mujer y la
igualdad de género y el fútbol me llega
un mensaje en twitter y es luís garcía y
yo te cai si a checar cuenta verificada
no se hiciera cuenta verificada hiciera
louis fuera me encanta lo que estás
haciendo como te puede ayudar y de luís
rafa márquez y charlyn corral y regina
blandón y rn ibarra y de repente se
empieza a sumar muchísima gente no sólo
el ámbito deportivo actrices empresarias
que dijeron es que esto tiene que pasar
y no sólo a nivel fútbol tiene que pasar
por muchas partes cómo te ayudamos vamos
a hacerlo me mandan llamar de federación
de fútbol mexicana fútbol
el mejor día de mi vida en federación y
así superiores voy a hacer la liga
femenil
así entré y salí así
pues me dijeron como que padre lo que
estás haciendo
no se puede y de paso if you can también
para el tren
pues justo una vez más como cuando me
dijeron la primera vez que si era niña
no debía de jugar fútbol
yo dije pues no como que no y salí dije
pues ahora va al doble tus armas y una
campaña en el que ya agarre a la gente
que estaba apoyando en movimiento al
salir a hablar nos pintamos tatuajes
simulando tatuajes que tenían valores
justicia igualdad de género trabajo en
equipo humildad y cada persona
comunicaba con su valor oye queremos una
liga femenil en donde se promueva la
equidad
queremos una liga femenil donde haya
transparencia queremos una liga femenil
queremos una liga femenil ha robado la
liga ha robado la federación y resultan
para mi sorpresa que esa campaña obtiene
10 millones de impactos en un solo día y
esa campaña le llega a la liga y le
llega a la federación donde existían
recursos pero se puede imaginar lo que
pasaba esta campaña creció tanto que
llegó a la fifa donde se pudieron dar
cuenta de lo que estaba sucediendo y
gracias a esta campaña se crea el gran
awareness que de alguna manera pone
contra la pared a nuestras instituciones
de fútbol en méxico y las fuerzas a
crear lo que es ya por primera vez
nuestra primera liga profesional femenil
en méxico
sigo platicando esta parte y aunque sigo
sin creerme el aire de plática varias
veces pero es que yo jamás me imaginé
que de un artículo de opinión que no era
una campaña ni nada parecido iba a poder
terminar ayudando a lo que ya llevaban
tantas mujeres tanto tiempo queriendo
lograr y bueno quien ya sabe que tenemos
una liga por cierto una liga femenil
bien me gustó hacer esta pregunta y yo
no sí pues ya tenemos una liga la liga
va bien y me pasó lo siguiente cuando
sale la liga y puesto me hubiera ya
lograse lo que tanto querías peleaste
por tantas mujeres aquí está ya porque
no estás jugando la liga porque no estás
jugando fútbol y me pasa una cosa muy
chistosa yo empecé fut sin género ya
cuando cayó bancario en cuenta que
alguien tenía que hacerlo dije claro
quiero hacer esto porque yo quiero jugar
fútbol pero me di cuenta cuando me
empiezan a llegar los mensajes de mamás
y papás de las mismas jugadoras de hoy y
fuera
yo ya no iba a jugar fútbol pero gracias
a ti puedo volver a creer puedo igual
perseguir mi sueño fuera gracias a ti
estoy jugando la liga que jamás pensé
que nuestro país iba a tener entonces
cuando recibí la llamada para ver la
oportunidad de convertirme en futbolista
profesional me quedé pensando mucho que
cuando uno cumple sus sueños cuando son
sueños personales te haces realmente
grande y te sientes muy realizado pero
cuando cumples el sueño con otras
personas es un sueño compartido te hace
esta ascendente
y yo creo que en un mundo como el de hoy
no tenemos que apostar a la grandeza que
está relacionada con el ego tenemos que
aportar a la trascendencia así literal
trascendencia y ahí está donde realmente
podemos cambiar el mundo puede empezar
pensando nosotros tener un sueño
personal una meta personal que eso te
hace que te muevas al principio pero
cuando te das cuenta que eso empezó así
y ahora estás tú abriendo la puerta para
el sueño de tantas otras personas
entonces no sólo hace más sentido
realmente estás moviendo al mundo y creo
que estamos en una perfecta oportunidad
ahorita para pensar cómo estamos
moviendo al mundo nosotros y si no cómo
lo podemos mover y no tenemos que ser el
presidente de la república no tenemos
que hacer gente con muchísimo dinero
porque a veces dejamos de hacer las
cosas pensando en un plan que empieza
así hizo que hay palabra esto tengo que
hacer esto estoy y nos vamos hasta el
infinito y obvio cuando llegamos ahí
decimos no pues está imposible así no
puedo llegar esto es qué pasa si nos
vamos paso por paso pero desde el primer
paso pensamos no sólo en nosotros mismos
pensamos en que esta acción nuestra
puede cumplir sueños
personas entonces si hay algo que yo les
pudiera dejar hoy es que no apuesten a
la grandeza apuesten a la trascendencia
piensen en el mundo y entonces de esa
manera realmente lo podemos cambiar
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]